the president of the united states says
joe biden is taking his first steps
today on the issue of guns in america
the executive actions include a call for
federal reviews on some specific gun
safety issues but
they're far short of the more sweeping
changes that many of the democrats want
we should jang is at the white house
with more on this story weisha good
morning to you now this is important
because
it comes after a series of mass
shootings what's what's going to be
announced today do you think
good morning to you gail president biden
is expected to launch a series of
modest measures like directing the
justice department
to issue new rules and investing in
community violence interventions
the white house stressed these are only
initial steps because gail frankly
there's only
so much the president can do by himself
why he is urging lawmakers to do
their part too among the actions
president biden is taking to address
gun violence an order to review federal
policy on so-called
ghost guns self-assembled weapons that
require no serial numbers
another would review the use of
stabilizing braces on pistols
which turns them into short barreled
rifles the president will also ask the
justice department to draft model
legislation
to implement red flag laws at the state
level
to prevent people facing mental health
issues from accessing firearms
president biden also plans to nominate
gun violence expert david chipman
as the next director of the atf an
agency that has not had a permanent
director since 2015.
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an
hour to take common sense steps
recent mass shootings like those in
georgia and colorado have once again put
gun violence
front and center as a candidate mr biden
promised legislation including a ban
on assault rifles in fact my first day
of office i'm going to send the bill to
the congress
repealing repealing the liability
protection for gun manufacturers
closing the background check loopholes
and waiting period
moderate democrats like west virginia's
joe manchin
have signaled they will not support the
sweeping reforms his more
liberal colleagues want it is time for
congress to act
and stop on cbs this morning last month
vice president kamala harris said
president biden
is prepared to act but urged congress to
take up the issue
i served in that body and i believe
that it is possible it has to be
possible
that people agree that these slaughters
have to
stop the nra is slamming president
biden's plan saying that they could
require
law-abiding citizens to surrender lawful
property the association
promises to fight but gun control
advocates like the group every town for
gun safety say this
is a victory that will save lives tony
everybody can agree you want to save
lives wija thank you very much